hey guys how's it going it's Justine
today we're going to be making a fruit
and yogurt smoothie if you guys haven't
seen any of my previous videos I
basically use a blender to make almost
everything and guess what a smoothie is
actually something that you should make
in a blender the lemon for me is usually
sometimes always a first thought of like
how can I make pizza in a blender how
can I make a cake how can I make cookies
also gonna need one banana half a cup of
yogurt blueberries sugar pineapple juice
some orange juice and a little bit of
milk and the strawberries first step
let's put all of our items into this is
a really great measurement handful
blueberries
more or less to taste half a cup of
yogurt I really feel like measuring that
so just like when you think it might
weigh 1/2 cup yea 1/2 cup that was
definitely a half cup we'll just put a
little extra and I guess 1/4 looks good
to me one and a half teaspoons of sugar
oops one wisp of milk good enough 1 tisp
of orange juice that looks good to me
now we got to cut up our strawberries
this is about 1 cup of strawberries ok
if this was this looks like a cup I
don't say to gain pools of strawberries
should be a little more precise hey now
it's time to blend this up
are you ready come and get it
and that's basically it hopefully if
you're like me and you like your
smoothies cold I'm going to put some ice
in here oh that looks so great add a
nice little straw here it is let's try
it it's really good I just want to let
you know that if you were to buy this
it's very smoothie here in Los Angeles
they've probably charge you $30 for it
look I can't I'm not even making that up
Mady he wants to try it's nice isn't it
go edge that has a banana yeah sorry
Jenna is allergic to banana but it's
okay it's good though my very good and I
sweet treat a nice sweet treat thank you
guys so much for watching this video I
will see you guys tomorrow for the next
summer snack leave me some comments
below and let me know what I should make
next and if you have any guesses on
tomorrow's video will hold see you guys
later
you